ein postbote der an der haustür klingelt
was die bewohner des mehrfamilienhauses
in rostock da aber noch nicht an der
mann der ist gar kein postbote sondern
ein wahnsinniger und er hat auch keine
pakete dabei sondern ein messer
der schock steckt rentner ernst gehen
noch immer tief in den knochen die
bilder des brutalen raubüberfalls er hat
sie ständig vor augen ein falscher
paketbote hatte ihn am sonntag
sechzehnter januar gegen 15 uhr 15 in
der rostocker im werk straße brutal
überfallen und schwer verletzt ich habe
den täter vorgehen lassen auf der treppe
der ist nach oben weiter gegangen und
ich bin hier
aufgeschlossen wenn man die wir
eingegangen
und die dritte war wollte ich die türe
zumachen
dann kam der täter von der travel wieder
runde und sprang hier mit voller wucht
gegen die tür und hat daran gehindert
die tür zu schließen dann haben uns hier
in entweder in diesem flur gerangelt er
hat mit ihr umfasst umschlossen hier um
brustkorb und hat mir dann mit einem
spitzen gegenstand
paar mal in den indie halsseite links
und rechts gestoßen ernst g hat
todesangst der täter vermittelt ihnen
dass es sich bei dem spitzen gegenstand
um eine giftspritze handeln könnte dann
drängt er den 82 jährigen in die wohnung
verlangt die herausgabe von bargeld und
wertgegenständen dann sagt er ich bin in
finanziellen schwierigkeiten in großen
finanziellen schwierigkeiten und ich
brauche geld
bringe sie mehr geld oder geben sie mal
geld raus und ich brauche auch die ihre
ec karte dann rief ich meine frau hilde
und hole unser wirtschafts geld von ihm
alles was wir haben das hat sie dann ja
auch gemacht ist im zimmer gegangen hat
die geldkarte und dass das bargeld was
wir je hatten vielen monat wirtschaft
geld ihm gegeben der täter durchsuchte
die ganze wohnung richtet ein chaos an
zerfleddert akten reist schubladen
heraus bedroht auch ernst gse frau hilde
ernst g muss währenddessen hilflos im
wohnzimmer in einem sessel am fenster
verharren und einmal war totenstille im
höre ja nicht mehr in ihm auch hummeln
und auch nicht mehr meine frau da bin
ich vom fenster aufgestanden und wollte
nach sympathie los ist und wie ich dann
in die anderen räume gestellt die feste
hat alles leer war die frau war
verschwunden und er war auch weg der
täter war geflohen seine frau zu den
nachbarn geflüchtet von dort aus hatte
sie geistesgegenwärtig die polizei
gerufen die auch gleich mit einem
großaufgebot anrückte suchende
polizeihubschrauber großalarm in rostock
evershagen ernst g muss mit seinen
stichverletzungen ins krankenhaus
der 82 jährige ernst die war nicht das
einzige opfer des falschen paketboten
hier in rostock kurz zuvor hatte der
brutale täter bei einer 66 jährigen die
nur wenige hundert meter entfernt von
hier wohnt zugeschlagen tatort kranich
weg ein einfamilienhaus mit vorgarten
hier lebt eine 66-jährige rentnerin
gegen 14.30 will die frau ihr haus
verlassen um eine zeitung aus dem
briefkasten zu holen plötzlich so konnte
sie den ermittlern später noch mitteilen
habe einen mann in einer paket austräger
uniform vor ihr gestanden sie brutal ins
haus zurückgedrängt und dann mit einem
messer mehrfach auf sie eingestochen
außerdem soll er die frau mehrfach ins
gesicht geschlagen haben wobei er
mehrere zähne ausschlug das opfer brach
blutüberströmt zusammen der mann verließ
das haus sofort wieder
mit den grafen ec-karten der opfer wenn
der täter zur nahegelegenen
sparkassenfiliale und hip geld ab die
polizei geht später mit diesen
überwachungskamera aufnahmen an die
öffentlichkeit und fahndet nach dem
brutalen täter die nachbarschaft in
rostock rövershagen ist beunruhigt
wenn sie klingelt so wie jetzt hier
jemand vor der tür steht man erst mal
noch im kopf man hat immer gedacht man
selber trifft es reinigt und denn so
nähe es ist schon komisch ist das schon
man hat richtig angst ja also man guckt
immer gleich es mal als über den zaun
dann alles in ordnung ist also man hat
schon richtig angst montag 17 januar 11
uhr der täter scheint noch nicht genug
zu haben versuchte es mit seiner masche
als falscher paketbote erneut doch
diesmal scheint die bewohnerinnen dieses
hauses ist eine vorahnung zu haben macht
die tür erst gar nicht auf hier in der
helsinkier straße im stadtteil lütten
klein scheiterte der falsche paketbote
mit seiner perfiden masche eine 31
jährige bewohnerin durchschaute den plan
und öffnete zum glück nicht ihre
wohnungstüren am ende schnappte das sek
den mutmaßlichen täter nur fünf
hausnummern von hier entfernt denn genau
24 stunden später rückten die
spezialeinsatzkräfte er an können den 37
jährigen mutmaßlichen täter festnehmen
schleppen ihn zu einem streifenwagen
nachdem wir gestern ja noch in die
öffentlichkeitsfahndung gegangen sind
auch bilder von überwachungskameras
veröffentlicht haben gab es also hier
zahlreiche hinweise aus der bevölkerung
und unabhängig haben sich also mehrere
hinweise auf einer person verdichtet und
hier gab es dann heute in den
mittagsstunden ein zugriff auch mit
einsatz des sek ernst g erholt sich
langsam von seinen stichverletzungen er
ist froh dass der mutmaßliche täter
gefasst werden konnte
dass wir den gefasst haben das
schlimmste was ich nicht halten konnte
wir indirekt uhr in die wohnung
eindringen konnte nicht und mir den hals
gestochen hat mich dazu das werde ich
mein leben
und eines steht für ernst gehe nun
leider fest man kann nie vorsichtig
genug sein auch nicht wenn scheinbar nur
die post gebracht wird